so i saw you and your wife were talking
about your real estate investments and
what you guys do in the real estate yeah
yup yup so kind of shed some light on
that because the real estate world right
now is crazy everything's super
high yeah so we've been in new york city
for the last 13 years i grew up in
syracuse upstate new york then i went to
new york city
and then um we just right before the
pandemic we moved down to atlanta the
label was down there um
cost of living cost of living was
quality of life everything you know it
was just like i'm out i couldn't do
another new york winner bro i was just
my my triple fat goose had seen enough
yeah so i uh we went down there and we
bought our first property and we just
the
the agent we connected uh jay rich he
just like he knows all of atlanta and he
ends up being a friend and a fan and all
that
so he's just been kind of steering us
and we started investing in this
neighborhood that's just going crazy and
so we just this past week we picked up
our fourth property
in two years
i was on we were on tour and i had to
like stop off at a notary and
sign and uh
it's funny man because like that same
day i had a friend pop out
um
he he's from syracuse he lives in
orlando he popped out ox and he was like
yo when are you gonna when are you gonna
pop out with something you're just like
when you go post something out like let
your nuts say you don't say like get a
chain get a car i was like nah get home
property i'm i'm buying real estate yeah
he was like oh you know it is funny i
was like dang
i really don't i really don't be pulling
out the flex we're just kind of
investing in what the the future looks
like for us because in my mind you know
this game of music is very similar to
sports it's like
you can have like a little window where
you can go crazy and then after that
people are like what's new what's next
100
so it's dope that i've been able to
continue to do what i do and and
have a fan base and stuff still keeps
growing but
i just kind of want to plan for if i
ever want to not have to go on tour or
you know what i'm saying say yes to
shows i don't want to no i mean look
there's artists
whose lifeline is literally touring you
know like like it's it's it's um without
the live shows like that's that's what
they depend on to pay their bills that's
right
some rap to pay the bill yeah i i i
don't i don't want to be in that
position and i want to have kids
eventually you know i'm saying me and my
wife and we like
man i just don't want to be running
around like this you know what i'm
saying i think like there's like
independent rappers without saying names
but like they've toured all year long
every year it's a tour and it's like
they're dope incredible artist but it's
like [ __ ] like yeah 55 dates every year
like half of your life is on the road
that's right that's right
it's like i couldn't imagine doing that
too yeah
yeah it just depends on what you value
you know i'm saying so like for me time
is the biggest thing so if i can
invest in real estate our game plan is
to basically have enough properties that
generate passive income for us that
anything music related is just extra and
so it's like the lifestyle is paid for
we got time back we can do what we want
and um
you know i think that's going to be the
next phase is
you're just you're just like having like
um
tenants or you're doing the airbnb thing
or yeah so we did airbnb for a little
bit and then the pandemic hit so then it
was like i know i was at an old body i
was at an airbnb in atlanta for sure for
like a week really yeah yeah in january
it was cold as [ __ ] yeah we had we had
everybody running and it started to pick
up it was going great and then the
pandemic hit nobody was traveling so
then we had to turn it into long-form
rental or whatever and so that's been
the game plan man just like rentals
right now because the mortgage is paid
the cash flows you know so that's for
those watching cash flow is
anything over which what you what your
cost is what your cost is and so the
goal for us is just
have that
right now the interest rate is killer
right so very very good interest rate so
it helps with your cash flow because
your your payment is going to be less
yeah absolutely